the
the various shots that people are
getting now
cover that they're they're you're okay
you're not gonna
you're not gonna get covet if you have
these vaccinations
[Music]
stretch reach for the stars
that needs to be on the top 10 of best
opening songs for conservative podcasts
of all time
i've had a lot of people ask me say
brian what is that that he opens to show
up with
and then he's another i guess my my mom
or somebody said what's he say what's it
say in the back
i'm like there's no words no i swear i
can hear something
they're saying something is this
subliminal brian okay
i'm like no put reading into it ain't
nothing there
ain't no they're there ladies and
gentlemen
welcome to the show my name is wayne
dupree and you are tuned in to
the best conservative coverage grassroot
coverage
grassroot recoverage grassroot coverage
here recovery exactly the internet we
we want you to share the show wherever
you watch it however you're watching
whenever you're watching
we want you to share our message what
we are doing let me introduce liabella
hello share the show right watch me
enjoy the show
everybody share the show and
our our uh our returning champions
[Laughter]
our play cousin our play cousin mr woody
mcadams what's up
morning good morning ladies and
gentlemen
shared yes share the show that's right
share the show before
before we get into the show let me say
you are a mighty fun
bunch of group of people that we have
well um our for those watching on rt
news thank you so much for watching us
it is our friday your thursday
as as you know but uh this is our last
show for the week
make it a doozy yeah let's let's let's
let's go ahead let's go ahead and kick
this thing off
before we go mypillow.com if you haven't
gone there before
i want you to go there after the show
don't go there doing the show i mean
now if you could do two things at once
and you want to do it on your phone
while you're watching the show
then do it there's a great specials
happening
at my pillow right now uh
i haven't yeah don't believe me you're
gonna make them show you his slippers
see i'll wear my moccasins i don't know
why this keeps
un un but i wear my moccasins all the
time
okay i wear my moccasins uh i have
another
set of slippers from my pillow i have
my pillows i have my uh
i have a king sheets for towels yeah
everything towels yeah the towel look
people there's so much
okay there's so much and
if you think about it brian leah woody
mike lindell knows to be
successful in life you have to have
something at home where you can rest
and that's what he has built his his
company on
for you to have for you to have better
days at school for you to have better
days at work for you to have better days
and whatever you do
you have to be able to rest at home
and and and and rejuvenate yourself
and you can do that with the mattress
topper you can do that with
the bed you can do that with the metric
you
you can do that with these things and it
gives you a successful
uh um start to the next day am i right
yeah people who work out regularly or go
to the gym regularly
you absolutely have to get eight hours
of sleep sometimes more i'm serious
if you want to stay healthy and fit and
you work out
absolutely must get rest right exactly
get a pillow yeah get the pillow i said
all i have is the pillow as of right now
i'm going to get the topper i think
because i
have back and hip issues so the topper
would be
very helpful for me but i travel a lot i
take my pillow with me
my pillow with me everywhere i go uh
just because
like wayne just said you have to get a
good good night's sleep wherever you're
at
um and you know most times hotel pillows
are garbage
none of that you don't want to know
where that came from
yeah eric swallow could have been on one
of those hotel pillows just remember
that oh no
just remember that him
think about that
eight nine three nine use the code name
wayne
okay uh we want to get another uh
awesome report from them uh because
honestly to tell you truth to get a
report from them to let us know
that y'all are taking advantage of this
code and also uh helping
your family out or helping yourself out
with their products
is a win-win for us we because
they believe in us we believe in you and
then you also believe in the product so
it's a circle of lights
um okay so with that said uh as
mccarthy yesterday i call it a game of
political chicken
my co-host might look at it another way
uh
this is where mccarthy wanted things to
go
uh and pelosi fell into the trap
um he put jordan and jim banks on there
uh i never thought
that pelosi could tell a republican
that they can't be on the committee i
know i mean i've never seen that before
if it's her committee can they do this
the selection process i mean you can you
can as the speaker
since it's a special committee and
they're picking they're deciding the
members
yeah yeah they do have some say in who
the members are if
for more powerful than the president
well for the for the
commitment yeah for the whole committee
so the republicans are allowed to submit
a list the republican
the minority leader is allowed to submit
a list uh
and final say falls to the uh speaker
right well that's why i think trump
should be speaker of the house but she's
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh man hold on
pelosi's got a republican already guys
what are we complaining about
on there no no she's already cheney
changed
right who got on the steps yesterday
after mccarthy did his thing
liz cheney came out and did her any uh
person who would be
third in line to the presidency must
demonstrate a commitment to the
constitution and a commitment to the
rule of law
uh and uh minority leader mccarthy has
not done that
last question i want to take a minute to
talk about uh
the appointments to the january select
committee
uh the rhetoric that we have heard from
the minority leader
is disingenuous uh the attack on this
building
on january 6 was the worst attack
on this capitol uh since 1814
it was an attack on our constitution we
supported
what would have been the very best
option which was a bipartisan
independent commission the minority
leader opposed that
he lobbied against it in the senate and
the senate blocked it
the american people deserve to know what
happened
people who did this must be held
accountable
there must be an investigation that is
non-partisan
that is sober that is serious that gets
to the facts wherever they may lead
and at every opportunity the minority
leader
has attempted to prevent the american
people from understanding
what happened to block this
investigation
today the speaker objected to two
republican members
she accepted three others she objected
to two
one of whom may well be a material
witness
to events that led to that day that led
to january 6th
the other who disqualified himself by
his comments in particular over the last
24 hours demonstrating that he is not
taking this seriously
he is not dealing with the facts of this
investigation but rather
viewed it as a political platform this
investigation must go forward
the idea that anybody would be playing
politics
with an attack on the united states
capital
is despicable and is disgraceful and i
am absolutely dedicated and committed to
making sure
that this investigation holds those
accountable
who did this and ensures that it never
happens again
and no dick must
be proud
she's not wrong she's have half of that
she's totally 18 the war of 1812
in 1814 british burnt the capital
dick must be proud
just saying can i just say this if i
would sit back and listen to that
and hear them talk about the way that
covet attacked us
we must found out who did this uh we are
america this can never happen on our
soil again
we need to find out who attacked us with
covid it's killed more people than
the civil war whatever that is what we
need to hear
right i mean honestly
why why no civil war was bloody much
i was just giving an example but what
i'm saying is why aren't they saying
this about covet if she could have got
behind covert like that
right i would have been proud but here
we are talking about something
nobody even had guns for it
zero had there there were people with
their white people really how many
congress people got shot and killed
how many did they find i mean let's
let's be if they hadn't been in no they
could have found them trust me they
could have found them no
they'd if they had been gathered if they
had seen somebody and got to them
look what they did to the police
officers that were trying to run
a police officer that shot and killed
ashley babbitt i know yeah
as she tried to enter look that's a
tragedy but she tried to enter
you can't do that she's coming through
the window they broke out glass coming
through the window like this with her
arms squished
what does she have in her backpack what
how do they know what she had look
i hear people defend cops all the time
and they're right a lot of the time
and this would be one of those times
they're right there was a mob of people
busting that already so why don't they
just shoot her not shoot everybody else
nobody came with
in the way of what woody is saying we
saw
what happened and we even said on the
show
the person that was
had taken the position to where ashley
babbitt was coming in the window
when she was coming in the window she
had two feet
on the on the um on the on the
desk or whatever that was the bottom of
the window yeah she had both
uh uh hands against the window
and and she and her body was coming
through
the person that was pointing the gun at
her
had her in his sights for at least
20 or 30 seconds he could have
shot at the ground no no no no no it's
illegal that's illegal
he could have shot at the wall no that's
illegal you can't be shooting
down you can't shoot objects yeah
whenever you just charge your weapon
it's got to be
oh it's a felony charge if you discharge
your weapon inappropriately which would
be in the air
well maybe okay well maybe he's a bad
shot
maybe he could have pardoned me play
that one off okay
maybe he's the one taser anyone i don't
know yeah
yeah that'd be a good place multiple
people multiple people were yelling at
her
gun gun gun and that didn't stop her
well we were yelling guns but she was
almost
through she was almost through by that
time from the cops who actually showed
her how to get in
uh a lawful hey but if you believe cops
cops were like this way guys that's how
you get in over here
and that's why you should have a
commission though right like that's why
this should be investigated
look it's not just one side that you
need to look at if there were people
that were complicit in letting people
into the capital
they should be held accountable too that
would be pelosi they're not being held
accountable and we still have people
in jail being held without charges
to this day six months into it well why
is the national guard held up
i mean they're terrorists people
set up chaz something that came out
yesterday when mccarthy was talking
that i did not know but
now i think that the democrat i mean the
democrat
and i know they probably won't do it but
the democrats have to answer the
question
mccarthy said on december 14th or
december 15th
they knew something was going to happen
right reports had been called in
around december 14th or december 15th
that something was going to happen on
january 6th
there was all kind i mean it was so
first of all there was a rally that was
planned and you knew
people were upset whether you believe
it doesn't have to be the mayor denied
needing um national guard mayor said no
no no we don't need nothing
this is all why you need to invest this
is why you need a real bipartisan
investigation but the problem is woody
every time we have one they cover up
stuff and that's the problem look what
comey's gotten away with look what
hillary literally bleach bit
an entire computer system and there she
is walking around probably going to run
for president again
the problem is it's not bipartisan it's
not bipartisan if it was
pelosi would allow jim jordan on there
no she wouldn't because jim jordan's not
biparti
he made him he verbally he went out in
public and made statements
he's made himself non uh he made him
democrats on there but
jim jordan represents americans
sure he said i know his brother
personally
he's a good old boy from the midwest uh
i don't i have an issue i have issues
with jim coach jordan
he's phenomenal and in his coaching
career at ohio state
he had nothing to do with any of that
and
he had nothing to do with it and not
reporting anything
that's probably innocent of all those
charges absolutely they want to lock
them up
because i grew up watching penn state
and i had this thing for that old dude
he well listen i can tell you an insider
story i know a man
that used to work with joe and he had to
and who's the guy that actually got in
trouble what's his name the dead the
guy's dead now
is he here no he's still alive he's in
somerset county prison who's the guy
that got in trouble
oh man why can't he give his name now i
cannot believe the defensive coordinator
for a
incredibly long time defensive yeah
defensive coordinator
had to talk to this guy that i know well
the
this defensive coordinator was sandusky
yeah sandusky was like so anyways i
swear i thought he was dancing
sandusky's in jail at somerset sci but
anyway in pennsylvania but anyway
sandusky was like oh man
joe paterno won't give me the keys to
the uh gym anymore so i can't get you
this guy wanted penn state paraphernalia
to give out to his group of people
uh at a special meeting and i can't name
the company because then i would get in
trouble
but sandusky said to this president of
the company
i can't give you any penn state
paraphernalia because joe
paterno won't give me the keys to the
gym
i can't get in there and there's a
reason why joe
wouldn't give him the keys the gym joe
admitted he knew what was going on but
he said he followed the right track
he reported it to the local police on
the college and then he turned a blind
eye joe was wrong
joey here saying joe was wrong
i don't like joe paterno i never did
okay but
anyways jim jordan jim jordan yeah i
know there's a must be so the pointless
family he's not the same guy completely
different
i know him i know his family and uh no
no that was not him either way either
way
i i mean honestly i don't believe and i
and i was schooled earlier
i don't believe that
pelosi should have the ability to
tell the other side what they can do and
what they can't do
but i've noticed in this particular
conference committee i know conference
uh whatever they call the house
commission 144th congress or something
what i've seen is democrats
do things to republicans that i've never
seen republicans do
to democrats like uh
they did something with uh margie taylor
greene right
yeah duties again though that's a that's
a
very uh specific situation
of her duties well republicans why is it
why is it aoc why isn't it why is an
arrow
there's a case
i haven't heard mccarthy go forward and
ask that uh because the
the republicans are behind they could
they could easily go ahead and they
don't do anything just the reason why if
jim jordan's not on the commission or he
is it doesn't matter because he's just a
mouthpiece
no one's getting arrested everybody's
like oh fauci's going to jail
that's great rand paul that you're going
to put on that big scene but felchy
isn't going anywhere
jim jordan's not going to get anything
done the democrats are going to make us
look like
crap and that we were terrorists on
january 6. we all know how this plays
out until the republicans take the
senate and tank the congress which is
what's going to happen in 2022.
so that's the end you entered the
capital illegally and you broke things
and you tried to enter the floor of the
capitol and you threatened people
you you were a terrorist
there was one video of that there was
i'm glad that you brought that up woody
and the sad part is do you know what's
worse than a terrorist
people that pushed the terrorists in
there they nancy pelosi wanted that to
happen
mayor mayor bowser refused
the national guard but that's what you
knew what was going on
i do i do a real investigation
you know what i'll never be one i was
thinking yesterday
i was like why is it that it seems like
that republicans are
trying to hide and stop this and i'll
tell you why
i thought that because i think donald
trump would revel in sitting down
and telling these people especially in
front of america
i didn't tell those people to do that i
didn't
i mean you can go and put
put the tape in i didn't call for this i
didn't tell them to do that
i think donald trump would sit down
there
for right in front of congress and tell
them to the face
they didn't do this because of me so
what do you can can i ask one question
woody
so then are the people illegally
storming our borders terrorists
yeah again
you enter you can still enter you can
enter you can crawl they ran through
they didn't ask for anything they ran
through
and they had drugs on them and guns
which makes them even bigger terrorists
yeah if you have drugs and guns then
sure i toss them and they're terrorists
right woody
i'm fine with that definitely that's
that's fine so then we need a commission
on that
thank you that would be nice to have
commission on the border
uh crossings illegal crossings yeah i
think that's great now
look guys in the chat room this is why
we have woody on because it's a great
conversation and look what we just came
up with
we need to have a commission on
terrorists that are crossing the border
we both agree on that see that
that's how you get stuff done i think
that's how you crack down on that so
if you finish the wall too right again
i just don't think yeah we got to block
the terrorists
i mean they might try to crash an
airplane into it like they did in 911
but
hopefully it'll keep the tariffs out i
think you gotta deal with the tunnels i
think you gotta deal with ports of entry
i think you gotta deal with uh airports
the places where most of stuff comes
across is places that people cross
legally at
i think you do need a commission i think
you do need to look in hey who's being
bribed
there's definitely bribes going on for
the amount of drugs to come across
there should be a commission into that
okay i'm 100 once one step at a time get
the border wall up all the way
then you can then you can go to the
airports then and the reason why you are
seeing a lot of arrests for drugs at the
port of entry
is because that's where the cops are the
cops aren't all up and down the wall
and that's where a lot of the drugs are
coming through in the football and
whatnot or under
or under bro i don't believe the wall i
i don't believe we should spend my walks
i don't think it'd be effective i do
think we should spend money on
more border patrol why don't you think
why don't you think it would be
effective because they were never
i've seen they've shown videos of people
just tossing bags over top of the wall
like do someone walk down the wall on
this side so walk up to the wall on that
side
you toss something over the drugs
whatever still get across but you can't
drive a giant truck over
right you can they cut holes in it they
pass stuff you can't drive a giant truck
over
there
you invest in technology drones
sensors you mean just effective with
drugs you don't mean with like humans
crossing because obviously it's more
effective with humans he just went
backwards
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
mean with humans i mean for everything
you're gonna slow down
i mean you're gonna have a pretty big
arm to toss 30 foot wall before you go
with that but why does people pull
through fences up why do we have fences
around the white house why do i have
fence around my house
because you have does because they also
have snipers sitting on top of the white
house when you jump that fight but they
got fences
what you're saying is we need a fence
and snipers down there
i like that idea
look if you want to put a fence up yeah
if you're if you're gonna say you're
gonna put a giant fence up the whole way
along the border
which again geographically speaking not
super possible but if you do do that
right there are some natural
hills and stuff that you don't need it
but yeah the majority of it all the way
but you need a ton of border agents and
if you're gonna put up all your if
you're gonna hire that many border
agents
you can just patrol the border use
centers and technology and save
millions of dollars on a wall well
well 24 7 middle of the night
you just don't have that kind of
manpower you can use this
idea though offense and snipers that was
a good one
you can use with with a border wall you
can
use sensors uh uh
as and and and have it have your
location
in the the um the guard room what not
you just have to have
more checkpoints to get to
specific spots when these things happen
you don't have to hire a hundred border
agents
you could hire 50 but just
add more places along the border
for check positions
like two or maybe four in it in one of
those houses or whatnot and
have it there so they didn't get to a
specific area at the time that
the sensors go off but you don't have to
hire a thousand more border agents and
stuff if you have sensors in place
i said i want i i say use border agents
and technology
walls are they sound great it sounds
like a good idea but it didn't work
the the the the phys the feasibility of
it just isn't great
but trump was doing it true did it how
much was built
god good let's go they were stopping him
oh man come on now don't go down that
road you're going to lose that one
the only reason why i'm laughing is
because i did see reports
of what what he was talking about there
was
fences that had fallen down there's
parts of the wall that were dilapidated
they needed
i think people got crazy with the whole
we replaced sections of fencing that
needed to be replaced
and that was racist that was silly but a
giant wall is also
not going to be effective you you you
really different things you do this a
lot of fencing
and you use technology
down there that have the wall they're
thrilled
no there's a lot of places that aren't
real intimate domain sucks
that that um okay well since we're on
the border thing the u.s
reaffirms its land border restrictions
with canada
um the united states will keep its land
borders with mexico and canada
closed for all 9th century travel
for at least another month that's
according to
department of homeland security uh
let's see to decrease the spread of
covet 19 including the delta variant
the united states is extending
restrictions on non-incentive travel
bullcrap
everybody's flying in planes wait what
so
so they're keeping us locked out of
canada and vice versa right
canada said that they'll let americans
in now starting what was it
august 9th well here's how i feel about
the u.s said that they're going to keep
those closed until august 21st at least
and then they'll re-up it in
it's stupid i don't think look we're
never gonna get a handle of this virus
and they're just gonna keep using it
against us unless we literally lock down
our borders and no one flies in
and no one flies out you keep your
country to yourself
and we keep our country to ourselves
that is the only way that we're going to
even possibly get this under control
and i think this is a good idea this is
a good idea but yeah the giant loophole
the same thing on salmon walls
the giant loophole of planes well
we just got monkey pox from nigeria
we're not stopping planes coming in from
europe but we're going to say you can't
come from canada or mexico
across the land mass border across the
fair canadians are posting
videos on tick-tock as they're
absolutely on complete 100
lockdown yeah that works yeah it's
silliness
i don't think i don't think we should
allow and that
you you can carbon races whatever i
don't think we should let anybody
in this country from china until we get
a handle on
uh i agree with that because we don't
know who speaks
right right and and what they did to us
as american people
um somebody posted on social media that
the
turk turkey box uh monkey pox was um
another distraction away from covet but
you know i mean i'm looking at some of
the
there was like the results or pictures
of this monkey park stuff
i mean that's 10 death rate that looks
like a chemical warfare project really
going
wrong oh yeah no if we're saying people
you can't come across the border from
canada or mexico yeah
we're telling people we can fly from
china
where where what's the you know what's
the logic to that i mean
we're saying we're trusting the science
what's the science say of
if you drive across the border or take a
ferry across the border
because it's it's really pretty cheap to
fly well yeah well
mona what is money it's because business
interest to go to with china that's the
a thousand percent the reason uh it's
the same reason the
it's the same reason movies won't
criticize china really
uh there is a ton of money there
there's a ton of money to be had by
people here both liberal and
conservative
and all those people agree together that
kova is not quite that important yeah
when lebron james contract is
up with nike he will officially be a
billionaire
from china from all from china chinese
slaves children
it's communism ccp hates us just
remember that they're communists
yeah i mean it it it i think they hate
us they love our money
they love our spending but they hate us
as humans yeah mccarthy
mccarthy was right they're not our way
of life
they hate the idea of america and they
just people being free
they said they're offended that the who
wants to re-open up the investigations
into
how kovitz started of course
i said i i bet russia would have been
real offended if uh people wanted to
investigate chernobyl
you know whenever you do something wrong
and you're trying to cover it up
it's super offensive whenever someone
tries to point it out
someone said leah the variant is coming
from the vaccine no
covet is mutating just like the flu does
but as it mutates
it gets weaker that's how viruses work
that's why i'm seeing
1800 people in california have covid and
the seven day death rate is five
that's a zero zero zero zero zero three
five death rate
was it again eighteen hundred to five
yes so here's how it goes so the seven
day ruling total is one thousand seven
hundred and fifty six people have
covered you
then there's five deaths over seven days
so it's point zero zero zero zero like
nine three percent death rate
um it's also not coming with a fever
anymore so your immune system isn't
recognizing it as a
the dangerous disease uh that it could
be it's just saying oh yeah my immune
system fight it off i don't need to burn
it out
um this is how typical viruses
move they get weaker as they go on
there's a scare tactic out there i
believe
and we're just gonna have to get through
it remember sometimes a more contagious
virus can actually be more deadlier
than a deadlier virus because it hits
more people with weaker immune systems
i i'm saying if you've got cancer if
you're over 60 and you're overweight
you need to worry a little bit about
this whether you want to call it a flu
or a virus
it may get you i'm just going to tell
you if you're one of those people and
you get the flu
and you get pneumonia you might die
right so that's how we need to look at
this but what i'm starting to figure out
here
is the fact that this virus is slowly
it's just mutating little itty bits
but it's getting more contagious because
it doesn't want to get more virtual
it doesn't want to get more deadly
because it'll kill itself and it'll kill
its host and then it won't be able to
survive anymore
so what it's going to do it's going to
get more and more and more contagious
and less deadly and then it's going to
become like a common cold so
we just got to get through it but the
problem is we need a good therapeutic
right now and we can't
until they approve the vaccines which is
in august and then it'll come out that
ivermectin's okay to take
can i look back to something real quick
we watched that video at the beginning
where biden said
if you had the vaccine that you can't
get covered
because that's that's that's wrong right
like yeah he should be kicked off
twitter right that is
misinformation our dear leader
i i listened i listened to a doctor last
night uh dr wynn she's an emergency room
doctor i can't remember her first name
but she immediately criticized him for
saying that she immediate
immediately criticized him for saying
that uh if you
if you had the vaccine you don't need a
mask anymore you have to worry about it
you have to worry about spreading it
because we don't know
we don't know you may not get as sick
from it if you had the vaccine but we
don't know that that means you can't
spread it
um because this new delta this new delta
variant
has a thousand more parts per million
to it's what the for the person carries
more contagious than the original
uh version of covid so we don't know the
effectiveness
of the of the vaccine as far as
spreading it
or as far as because he said you don't
get sick in general which also
isn't true right like it's supposed to
make your it's supposed to make your
symptoms
milder but we don't know yet
but would your symptoms have been milder
anyways so my question is why do you
think he lied
uh full frontal why do you think do you
think it's because he has dementia
or do you think it's because he just
likes to lie no i think it's because
he's working off information he had
it he had information old information
and he just used it because it sounds
better
because it used it and it sounds better
and look this is something people this
is something that the left criticized
trump for
and they should criticize uh biden for
because
he put this out there and i think that
the underlying reason is
is to get the to keep the economy moving
because
every president wants to have a good
economy because if you want to win
re-election
you win re-election through people he's
not running he's not running again
he's been i think he said he wasn't he
said he was too old
unless it's stolen but um or he forgot
uh
biden if we look back over the last
couple of
weeks biden came out and was um talked
about the door to door
right right yeah we learned that the
door to door had been
already happening for about two or three
months before biden came out and said
that
last night biden came out and said that
uh
you can't get covet if you get the cover
vaccine
but for the last but last three or four
weeks
cnn and msnbc have been saying that
regularly on their broadcast
in the morning they get out there and
they say y'all need to get out and get
the vaccine because you can't get kobe
well it wasn't a minute i was like it
wasn't untrue
until like a month ago three weeks ago
that wasn't untrue information the
science hadn't said something different
yet
but over the last two weeks they should
have known better like i mean
report no better no reports over the
last
month and a month or so were showing
that people were getting caught
people were coming out and saying i got
coveted after i got the cobra vaccine
yeah yeah right i apologize i was miss
thinking about it but uh but you know
it's
there's always been a possibility of it
if you get the vaccine
there's never been a point where it's
been a zero percent chance right
what about polio and measles and all
that stuff nobody gets it after they get
the vaccine well
that's where you get the vaccine that's
how hurt immunity works you get enough
people get the vaccine
the virus can't spread the virus dies
right like it can't spread anymore it
dies so that's how vaccine goes
the needles goes away so vaccines in
general are not a hundred percent
vaccines in general aren't 100 it's just
you get enough of the population
vaccinated
that the virus can't move so it might be
stable to still
infect a few people but if you keep it
to just that few numbers what about
those people who brag about never
getting a vaccine their entire life
they're healthy
they're lost they're they're the people
bringing measles back but they've never
gotten sick though
yeah it's again look anthony robbins kid
he never had one he never been sick let
me play this
already protected because everybody else
got it in some cases let me play it
let me play democrats by not voting this
motion to proceed tomorrow
pointing to the fact that it's been done
many times so
what is your response are republicans
are you wanting this bill
to die senator blunt covered that
the majority leader will not be slowed
down
by having this motion
to proceed to the bill defeated
all that does is give him the
opportunity
to move to reconsider god damn it i said
the wrong is wrong
go ahead jen more than 10 of the
traveling party with these texas
democrats
now claim to have a breakthrough case is
there any concern that this trip that
was intended
to advocate for voting rights is now a
super spreader event
in washington well i would say that's
not a characterization we're making from
here
we certainly understand there will be
breakthrough cases even vaccines that
are
incredibly effective are not foolproof
they're not 100
effective we've seen that here's the
good news though we know that
these vaccines that these individuals i
think if i'm correct have have been
vaccinated
uh it means that protects from death it
protects from serious illness it
protects for the most part from
hospitalization
uh so that is a good sign protect from
death
no i've heard some people die oh yeah
everyone died from the backbone itself
protects
a very small number it's still a number
protects protects from hospitalization
no i've seen people claim that
optimizations are
up for the for this
after after getting it or
yeah for because they get coveted
but they were she's quick to say
i wouldn't i wouldn't characterize it as
a super spreader
but you can characterize the white house
under the trump administration
for inviting people to sit
without mask you can characterize that
as a super spreader
but not the texas democrats who
who the virus is going through like
herpes
okay so they probably don't have
anything
420 000 reports of adverse
uh reactions and effects over almost i
think we're at
uh cdc reporting ten thousand deaths
some are saying and there's a
whistleblower saying up to 45
000. uh you know
whether we find out we need to have a
commission on this
who's making the money where's the money
going to and why all these people dying
this is what i would like to say if i
could have the floor for just a moment
um we will know we all know that they'll
be
jacksonville we all know that there'll
be vaccine deaths that they'll be
coveted deaths but the problem is
there's one thing that no one's talking
about
and it's natural immunity from covet if
you've already had coven
and i shriek every time i see someone
who had coveted
get the vaccine because i can tell that
they've been uninformed
there was just a week ago it came out
from israel
and israel has been ahead of the curve
they have been the trailblazer when it
comes to
covid the vaccines uh therapeutics
they are way ahead of the curve and they
just announced
that it looks as though natural immunity
is 700
greater protection than the shot and
this comes from the data from the
israeli
government okay why aren't scientists
talking about this
now the reason i'm asking all three of
you this is
because it proves that covid
is become political and that is why we
four here are arguing on
well it's only a small percent that died
from the vaccine and well
kovitz only the flu it's because we
can't figure out what is the truth
anymore
and what isn't so then we all run to
these links and try to find something
that makes our side believable
the truth of the matter is you have to
look at the data
and if anybody could tell me right now
how many people are dying in the
hospital
that were previously infected with covid
if you can tell me that number because
you can't because there aren't any
what we are seeing are unvaccinated
people in the hospital dying
and vaccinated people in the hospital
dying you're correct
vaccinated people aren't dying at higher
rates but some are still dying
but why hasn't the white house come out
and say hey we need to have a
conversation on those
that have natural immunity and we need
to do some studies
why isn't that being done there is so i
was just
looking it up because i i had read this
earlier and i couldn't remember it
but you were talking about it so nih
is actually doing a study about natural
immunity
to see the effectiveness against the
vaccine
as of right now uh it is
there are basically a ton of variables
that's essentially what the article is
reading
there's a lot of variables based on
protein spikes etc
how you were how you were infected the
um the dose of the infection uh causing
the protein spike
butter changes here i'll just i'll make
it easy for you here's a study that was
done
835 792 israelis known to have recovered
from the virus
72 instances were reinfection amounts
were 0.0086 percent of people who were
already infected with covid
none of them died and they didn't even
get a mild infection in fact
they were pretty much asymptomatic
there's your study that's a real time
study not an nih
bought and paid for by our democrat
super pac
and then you have i'll take proof of
that anytime but then you have the gop
these shots need to get in everybody's
arm
as rapidly as possible but we're going
to be back in a situation in the fall
that we don't yearn for that we went
through
last year
sounds like a threat to me yeah 1999
there there's a report that's coming out
now saying back in 99
2000 they saw uh where
fauci and others started filing patents
on uh the the covet 19 having to do with
coven 19
having to deal with all kinds of uh
every variables that have to do with
field 19 as that thing started to ramp
up
and they start testing it and started
pushing it and then in 2012
the government said ah can't be doing
that here like this anymore
this gain of function you can't do that
here so
they took it overseas went to china so i
know we're talking about blaming the ccp
however i'm blaming our own damn
government for being involved in this
damn thing for the money
and for taking it to china and being
able to do it in china because china has
no rules
about anything you're doing if you got
the money we know obama sent the money
over
we saw that uh fouchy and obama tour in
the lab and wu
this is sick these are sick people that
are running this thing
they need to be held accountable for it
no one will be that's the sad part
republicans don't fight hard enough and
democrats don't want it right you see
this one turtle
who's on the door of china you'll be
with me on this one woody
i rail against the turtle all day let's
son of a biscuit
this dude is as dirty as the day is long
and his wife chao
her sister's the head of the largest
shipping corporation
tied to the chinese government and yet
this is cool
yeah no i'm with you on that one i i i
have tons of issues with
mcconnell in fact i think he is
he is definitely losing he shouldn't be
in there he's as old as
is by maybe not i don't think he's
losing it i think
mitch mcconnell is i think a
horrible thing for our government um i
think he grinds stuff to a stand still
all the time but i also think he he is
the reason he can do that
he's the most knowledgeable guy
no there's a reason why you say that too
i mean i understand why you agree
about that one you know but okay yeah
yeah yeah well you talk about somebody
brian itself that was kind of fast so
you're like oh yeah oh hell yeah
mcconnell yeah i'm high five and i'm all
in
yeah somebody grinded something to a
hole
i mean that's what they do up there they
walk out
mcconnell is a master though here's the
thing you got democrats jumping on a bus
driving to d.c yeah i see that was a
little bit
again the the texas democrats but it's
not the first time they've done it no
trump said said pelosi no you're
grounded you're getting on that plane
get the hell back here
democrats always trying to leave town
they were man they were so pissed off
getting off that bus
the memes were epic
they were so angry that trump had
stopped them
from taking off to go into another
country european vacation is what they
were getting ready to do
they're dragging their bags back back to
the capitol building
trump hey trump said y'all can go but
you ain't but you ain't using
uh taxpayer money yeah real quick
i know we're probably going to be
talking about security hacks coming up
soon in the next block and i just want
to tell you that
there's some breaking news here there's
911 outages
all across the country right now in
multiple states and i'm just
hearing word now from a good friend of
mine who is
inside of um some
domain name system and he said it's a
huge system
that ensures all domains in the internet
are converted and functioning properly
and he said right now the dns server is
completely down
um also some of the websites and
something was hacked
and those are very big systems that's
coming from him right now he said when
you enter a domain name it converts it
to a code
that directs it to a website and it's
not working over 30
000 websites are currently down
worldwide including major news outlets
and 911 is down is this almost
definitely nothing we're talking about
this is almost definitely a hack it
absolutely is i'm telling you we've
heard there's multiple states
multiple states with their 901 systems
down yeah something dirty is going on
right and they're throwing out yep and
they're throwing out these testing flags
because the big hack will come and
that's what i put on my twitter account
i said look
this is just the beginning be prepared
because it's gonna it can get really bad
really quick
you think coveted was bad you should see
an emp
this is the new cold war this is the
start of the new cold war that's true
i mean this is a hundred percent it's
not nuclear anymore it's it's cyber and
it's
it's it's it's because we're the we we
have the biggest uh uh
cage to rattle i mean no one wants to
come mess with the us or our military is
the turning point yeah no i don't think
no it's it's
it's the high point everyone knows that
military-wise you cannot assault the us
for no no country is making an attempt
to but
you can use guerrilla warfare
online you can you could use a digital
guerrilla warfare
and attack our systems and break us down
you
and again we go back into we don't
invest in infrastructure
we don't invest inside we don't invest
in cyber surveillance
yeah they're not even putting much in
that building the money going to cyber
though is uh being shared with this
climate change climate change and
environmental natural disasters there's
only
47 uh million dollars being split
between the three
which is pennies which is pennies let's
see let's be honest it's a shame that
we're eating
climate changes all the time it's a
shame i believe
climate change
you know i believe i believe in climate
change i'm sorry
yeah winter spring summer fall
um
okay so uh you brought up you brought up
the thing about the uh
yeah yeah it's it's definitely
uh scary when you start to see these
things i just
wanted to warn the audience that you got
to be prepared because have a
safe meeting place with your family just
in case if you're split whenever this
goes down you don't know how
vulnerable you'll feel whenever you
don't have your cell phone and you can't
hear the tv
and you can't get a hold of anyone
you're going to feel very vulnerable so
you need to be able to meet somewhere
with your family it's going to happen
i promise every family should have an
emergency plan yeah just just together
just in general i mean if you're the
head of your family
uh whatever you should get with your
family gather them together
and tell them hey we need to come up
with a plan in case any natural disaster
happens
uh whatever it might be you should have
a plan with your family
of her house caught on fire how do we
get out
what do we do if everyone's not home
what do we do yeah i mean like
after this same year
if you have a family of your husband and
wife
kids what not y'all listening you have a
family and you
don't have a plan there's something
really wrong with you
this year should have been the wake up
call
as you all needed as time you get right
with god
i'm just saying yeah meats and waters
and
antibiotics in your closet because you
just don't know what's going to happen
ups fedex u.s bank
airbnb all these websites now
[ __ ] guys it's yeah it's bl it's bad
i'm not listen they were talking about i
couldn't understand what this meant
maybe some people in the audience could
tell me
everybody was uh i saw a lot of chatter
online about this black
swan event i couldn't understand i
didn't know what black swan event was
a lot of people were questioning what
does it mean they were thinking it meant
a cyber attack like this in the united
states but
that's really concerning wayne if you're
saying that all of these
um websites are down
yeah it's pretty crappy i had some
go-kart parts that i've
been waiting on for a while now man this
is garbage
yes i'm telling you i didn't look right
yeah but this is
it it's absolutely they attacked our our
fuel lines they attacked our oil set our
oil refineries
they attacked our uh meat processing
plants and there is essentially zero
retaliation for that
yeah uh that's your man joe biden no
what he doesn't like joe biden very much
okay he hasn't got it yet but he'll tell
you
he's not that's the man in charge right
now oh yeah yeah
one million votes look for this this
this empty shell of a human being
and when i said i used to jump around
saying emperor has no clothes
under barack obama oh oh no
barack obama's fully clothed this one
this one is stark naked and everybody
thinks he's dressed
i have i have plenty of issues with
biden i will give him credit he called
out china recently
as being um
we need to do more than call china out
it's time to get the guns
it's time to get some guns it's time to
get the bomb i don't like guns and bombs
but i know
it's war it's war i'm full while
analysis this is world war
iii it truly is world war i'm ready for
war with the ccp if we attack
a real visual of the world globe
from 20 2000 to 2020 and it showed in
china's trade which was predominantly
just in china
to now 2020 and it literally
is all china has created and made itself
the hegemony
of all of europe and the east
yep and we're sitting here what a pants
now
they're just stupid they're on american
land
they own american land they have spies
in all of our colleges
they're making our antibiotics and our
heart medicines
china is controlling us more than what
joe biden is controlling us
okay so again they're probably
controlling through joe biden
it's
i don't think it's military action i
think it's well let me rephrase that
it's not traditional military action it
might be cyber
you know cyber retaliation if somebody
dropped a bomb on one of our oil
refineries we would drop a bomb back
if you're going to cyber probably not
not with joe he
if you're gonna if you're gonna use a
cyber attack on our country
we need to find out who the perpetrator
is and it needs to be retaliated against
you you need to hit them back just as
hard as they hit us it looks like god's
hitting china pretty hard right now with
uh flooding that they've never seen
before so
you know karma works i mean look at the
american soccer team they all knelt and
then they lost
to sweden three times now china's being
flooded so bad that they've never seen
floods like this in the history of
floods so
you know god will get you by the way
that was predicted i don't know if you
guys know
that it was predicted already
the floods in germany china all that
it's in the bible we
just have to go we have to go ladies and
gentlemen
uh we hope that you have an awesome week
in uh i want to thank leah
brian woody woody thanks a lot for uh
joining us this week and um and
everything that you have he seen or
heard or
have listened to and taken in or not
taken in
do some research do some research and
come up with your own conclusions times
out of ten you're gonna be like
damn i agree and then you'll be like nah
i don't agree but i'm gonna go research
and try to find out
whatever but that's what we're asking
you to do
and as you are researching make sure
that you check out cbdline.com forward
slash
wayne dupree use the code name wayne for
off on your product purchase they have
so many
pain relieving products uh
on their website that that is too good
to pass up
yeah i actually want to bring up one of
our top fans deborah
in the chat i won't say her last name
but she said that she has r
r a i think she actually uses arthritis
yeah i think that's what she has um she
actually uses the lotion on her feet
and it actually helps her feet so for
those of you that have autoimmune
diseases try to get the lotion and see
if it'll work on your feet
and on your elbows and on your knees
because she says that it's actually
working i
i see debra she's still on there maybe
she can attest to it again but
i thought that was a great point and i
wanted to bring that up
yeah my mother said she puts it on her
feet before she goes to bed and if she
has to get up in the middle of night or
the morning whatever
she can physically get up and it's all
right
everybody's asking for a two-hour show
saying if you're gonna have
more people on you need more time
a two hour show we gotta have our own
little song like gilligan's island
four hours i tell you what i tell you
what two hour show
patreon.com forward slash wd that's
right
help us help us i mean help you to help
you
yeah help help us go there
and uh i don't know five dollars ten
dollars a month help us
that's a cup of coffee that's a cheap
dollar fifty cup of coffee come on man
once a month yeah
yeah yeah and i mean we got to hear a
lot of different viewpoints today
um i like getting inside a person's head
who isn't just a conservative and
agreeing with me uh and i think man you
just chased him off
yeah no but uh i think it's i think it's
fun
i i like to do that yeah i don't like
just an echo chamber
i like to debate i like to get my point
across and guess what what do you
actually agree there needs to be a
commission for the terrorists coming
across our border
you know that could be replayed trump
sometimes watches the show
i mean so maybe he'll retweet that what
i'm just saying is it's a lot of fun to
have an open conversation
with different opinions so god bless
america that we can still do that
for the moment there you go that's all
yo it's been awesome uh patreon.comwd
show
and um yeah you want two hours get there
exactly exactly all right um
time for our awesome music
[Music]
okay